[Music]
the coronavirus may feel like it's
everywhere but your chances of surviving
it depend on where you are in many cases
indigenous people remote communities
they're especially vulnerable if the
virus arrives there sometimes they're
just so far away from the health system
it's difficult to get sanitizing
supplies to them to prevent sickness and
no hospitals around if they do get sick
fear of the corona virus has caused many
to seek even more distance pushing
deeper into jungles and forests further
away from the virus but also further
away from help
[Music]
in for zulan in today's covert 19
special what the coronavirus means for
people living in isolated parts of the
world my sister in Far North Queensland
for example she says she feels safe
being so far away from it all but what
about indigenous communities they're
under strict lockdown and extremely
susceptible to disease same case in the
Amazon the virus not only poses a threat
to its inhabitants but also to the
rainforest itself
Brazil's indigenous peoples are afraid
this tribe in Minas Gerais State is
worried that the corona virus could soon
spread to them we are asking for help
because we indigenous peoples are
neglected by the state we are afraid
that we will starve because nobody knows
how long the corona crisis will last
there's hardly any intact rainforest
left to flee to so this tribe is forced
to tough it out it's a very different
story further north in the Amazon basin
here many Native communities are taking
control of their own destiny by shutting
off their reservations and putting up
barriers against intruders and against
the virus experts believe the virus
poses more of a threat to indigenous
people than other communities
now each sabe can we do my see we know
that indigenous people gets sick faster
develop more severe symptoms and are
much more likely to die from it
their immune systems are more
susceptible to viruses of all kinds this
is why some of the tribes have even
withdrawn into the jungle just like the
alwah seen here in pictures from before
the corona virus the alwah live far from
the nearest settlement they hunt monkeys
and live on berries from açaí palm trees
they live as they did over 30 years ago
when they were completely isolated
criminals are taking advantage of the
retreat of the indigenous people to
destroy parts of the rainforest
authorities report a 50% increase in two
forestation the invaders are Lumberjacks
gold miners and illegal hunters they
bring diseases with them the Brazilian
state must now drive all illegal
intruders out of there in the capital of
Amazonas State Manaus hospitals are
already reaching capacity and already
there are coronavirus related deaths
among indigenous people in 2019 a dam
owned by a mining company collapsed
killing hundreds it was a disaster for
the indigenous people in manizer ice
mining waste poisoned the rivers and now
there's the danger of coronavirus you
will part out before a river is almost
dead because a criminal act by a mining
company caused a disaster because of
this we can no longer grow anything
multiple dangers for a community with
little to no protection
that report was filed by Matias EBIT he
joins us now from Rio de Janeiro is that
best for the indigenous people of the
Amazon to retreat even further into
remoteness yes it's definitely the best
way for them to protect themselves and
to isolate deep into the jungle and the
indigenous people they're vulnerable and
the immune system is not as strong as
that of other brazilians they have less
antibodies and if we look into history
in the 70s there was already a mass
extinction of indigenous people in
Brazil and by illegal loggers and miners
who entered the Amazon region because
the military dictatorship they built
highways into the Amazon and this mass
extinction is still part of the memory
of the indigenous people here so what
should the government be doing to get it
right the government should protect them
and should provide help that no illegal
loggers and - enter these these
indigenous lands which are protected by
the constitution of Brazil but in in in
real in the real life there is no
protection for them at all and during
the government of also narrow the main
bodies and the main state agencies are
weaker than before the Funai the
indigenous state agency and as well the
environmental police they have less
money and less power it doesn't sound
like the indigenous have the backing of
the state even before the crisis the
president wanted to open the Amazon to
development button our always was keen
to open the indigenous land for mining
and other activities and now it's
actually happening and during the first
month of this this year during the
corona crisis and the deforestation is
on a record high so how would you say
the president is handling the crisis in
general considering he recently fired
his health minister he's acting like a
real populist also narrow his motto is
economy first and he's not defending
isolation methods so he's like let's say
a poker player and his type of bet is
that the corona crisis will not
be as dramatic as scientists and predict
so he's a little bit betting and things
that social turbulence this could be
much worse for Brazilians than the
corona death mattias a bet reporting
from Brazil now to the questions you've
been sending us about the corona virus
have been so many our science editor has
hardly left his home office poor Derek
but I know the feeling I was home five
weeks straight here at Derek's answers
how does covert 19 kill is that the
virus itself or a patient's immune
response the virus attacks and kills
cells obviously as it's replicating
itself but in the course of this disease
it often appears that your body is its
own worst enemy when you're infected
with kovat 19 it triggers an immune
response in your body that manifests as
symptoms like fever or diarrhea them
they're meant to contain stars co2 and
to try to stop it from making more of
itself while while these killer cells in
your immune system sort of sweep the
virus up and in about four out of five
patients who have symptoms everything
works as it should but in about one out
of five the new corona virus is able to
attack lung cells that produce
substances that are critical to getting
air into and out of your lungs now when
that happens the immune system can go
into overdrive its invading and
destroying the lung tissue in an effort
to keep the infection under control as
the damage in the lungs mounts up
pneumonia isn't far behind one
particularly dangerous complication is
what's known as a cytokine storm which
can quickly prove fatal
what is a cytokine storm and why is it
dangerous cytokines are signaling
molecules released by immune cells that
cause inflammation now inflammation is
actually part of the body's immune
response to something like the invasion
of a pathogen the problem is when the
checks and balances in the immune system
don't work correctly and the immune
cells continue to churn out cytokines
kind of unmask even when they're no
longer needed the inflammation reaction
spirals out of control and the vast
numbers of cytokines began attacking the
body's tissues that's that's a cytokine
storm in kovat 19 patients who've had
severe cases it's often what's causing
death and over-the-top reaction of the
immune system can cause much more damage
to organs like the lungs than the virus
itself in younger patients in particular
doctors now believe it might even be the
primary cause of mortality his ozone
therapy effective against kovat 19 bone
is an unstable molecular form of oxygen
it's a gas that naturally occurs in the
atmosphere where it absorbs a lot of the
harmful ultraviolet radiation emitted by
the Sun that would otherwise strike our
planet now the gas is a very powerful
oxidizing agent which means basically
that in chemical terms it's pretty
dangerous stuff now I had never heard of
a therapy before or alternative or
otherwise a quick search however
uncovered guidelines from the US Food
and Drug Administration that are pretty
clear about it not being a good idea to
try to use it for medical purposes in
fact high levels of ozone can damage the
lungs severely so I would steer well
clear of any therapies that claim to use
it
well that was alcove of 19 special for
more go to our website DW comm we've got
a dedicated section on that pan
and it's in 30 languages finally a quick
look at some of the only 15 nations that
are yet to record a case of the corona
virus in Asia we're talking about North
Korea to Menace tan Tajikistan which all
maintained they haven't registered a
single case of covert 19 but
international observers have cast doubt
on some of those claims in Africa
risotto and Comoros say they too have
been spared from the pandemic so far
let's hope it stays that way and in
Oceania about 10 island nations have
recorded zero cases thanks in part to
their geographic isolation which is
exactly what our show has been about
today the pros and cons of living in
remote parts of our planet I'm Ben
fazool and in Berlin thanks for joining
us
[Music]